GOOD EVENING, HAPPY
THANKSGIVING.
I AM MIKE EMANUEL AND FOR
BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TAKING A
HOLIDAY FROM HIS TWITTER HABIT
TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT IS CONTINUING HIS
CRITICISM OF THE FEDERAL
JUDICIARY IN GENERAL, AND
SUPREME COURT CHIEF JUSTICE
JOHN ROBERTS IN PARTICULAR.
IT COMES IN A THANKS GIVING
HOLIDAY WHEN THE PRESIDENT
EXPECTS HIS THANKS TO HID THEIR
TROOPS WHILE STAYING CLOSE TO
THE HOME.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE AS OF
THE PRESIDENTS RESORT AT
WEST PALM BEACH TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, MIKE.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU AND HAPPY
THANKSGIVING.
THE PRESIDENT SPENDING THIS
BENIGN EVENING, 2019, HAVING
THANKSGIVING DINNER AND
SPENDING TIME WITH HIS FAMILY.
SOMETHING HE BEGAN THE DAY BY
THANKING THOSE WHO ARE NOT QUITE
AS LUCKY.
>> THOSE LOOK LIKE PRETTY GOOD
SANDWICHES.
I DON'T WANT ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY LOOK VERY GOOD.
>> >> IS A TIME-HONORED
THANKSGIVING TRADITION FOR
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF,
EXTENDING THE GRATITUDE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO THOSE WHO
SERVE AND PROTECT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOING SO TODAY,
BOTH IN PERSON AND BY PHONE.
>> I WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
PROFOUND GRATITUDE FOR THE
EXTRAORDINARY SACRIFICES YOU
MAKE TO DEFEND OUR NATION WHILE
YOU ARE AWAY FROM YOUR FAMILIES
AND LOVED ONES.
>> IT WAS A VISIBLE OUTPOURING
OF APPRECIATION FROM MR. TRUMP.
STILL, IN STARK CONTRAST TO HIS
PREDECESSORS.
PRESIDENT BUSH PAID A SURPRISE
VISIT TO U.S. TROOPS IN IRAQ
OVER THE THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY IN
2003.
PRESIDENT OBAMA MET WITH TROOPS,
BOTH IN 2010 AND AGAIN IN 2014.
MR. TRUMP'S COMPARATIVE ABSENCE
HAS DRAWN SHARP CRITICISM FROM
SOME, EVEN SPARKING SPECULATION
THAT HE SIMPLY DOESN'T WANT TO
GO.
DEFENSE SECRETARY JIM MATTIS
REJECTED THAT NOTION, ADDING
THAT SECURITY IS ALWAYS A
CONCERN.
THE PRESIDENT IS THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF AND HE DECIDES WHERE HE
NEEDS TO GO.
THERE ARE TIMES I DON'T WANT HIM
IN CERTAIN LOCATIONS."
WHILE THE PRESIDENT DID HINT
TODAY, AS WELL AS EARLIER IN THE
WEEK THAT HE DOES INTEND TO
VISIT AMERICAN TROOPS ABROAD,
THERE WAS NO AMBIGUITY ABOUT HIS
FEELINGS ON BORDER SECURITY.
SITTING AGAINST THE DAY THAT HE
AUTHORIZED AMERICAN TROOPS IN
THE U.S.-MEXICO BORDER, TO
USE LETHAL FORCE IF NECESSARY
AGAINST AN APPROACHING GROUP OF
MIGRANTS.
ALSO THREATENING TO CLOSE THE
"WHOLE BORDER," IF IT MEANS
PROTECTING AMERICANS AND SEE IF
SOVEREIGNTY.
>> IF THEY HAVE TO, THEY WILL
USE LETHAL FORCE.
I'VE GIVEN THE OKAY.
I HOPE THEY DON'T HAVE TO.
BUT YOU KNOW, YOU ARE DEALING
WITH A MINIMUM OF 500 SERIOUS
CRIMINALS.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO LET THE
MILITARY BE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
I HAVE NO CHOICE.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS ALSO ACTIVE
ON TWITTER THIS THANKSGIVING
DAY, INCLUDING A PAIR OF
MISSIVES AIMED AT SUPREME COURT
CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS AND
THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS, WITH WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SPARRED OVER
A NUMBER OF, THEY FEEL,
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED LEGAL
CHALLENGES TO THE TRUMP AGENDA.
INCLUDING BORDER SECURITY AND
ASYLUM POLICIES.
>> I KNOW THAT CHIEF JUSTICE
ROBERTS, JOHN ROBERTS, HAS BEEN
SPEAKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO USE SOME
COMMON SENSE, THE NINTH CIRCUIT,
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT'S TOTALLY OUT
OF CONTROL.
IT'S A DISGRACE, FRANKLY.
ESSENTIALLY, THEY ARE
LEGISLATING, THEY ARE SAYING
WHAT TO DO.
>> MIKE, IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
THIS OUT.
THERE ARE A ARE A PARTY PLENTY
OF REASONS TO BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WILL FOLLOW
THROUGH ON HIS THREAT TO SHUT
DOWN THE "WHOLE BORDER."
YOU MAY REMEMBER IT WAS BACK ON
MONDAY WHEN THE PORT OF ENTRY